c'était il y à 22 ans
hong kong redevenait un territoire
chinois après un siècle et demi sous le
drapeau britannique 22 ans c'est aussi
l'âge des deux figures de proue du
mouvement pro-démocratie jo choix ou on
gagne est chaud que l'on voit ici lors
d'une manifestation en jeu et voici
l'image du jour
les deux jeunes hong kong et dans un
fourgon de police arrêtés et accusés
pour un rassemblement illégal en juin le
régime tente de créer une terreur
blanche pour tétaniser les manifestants
mais le mot d'ordre reste le même week
end
nous ne nous rendrons pas affirme le
jeune activiste déjà emprisonné à trois
reprises son mouvement des mocistes au
réclament le droit à l'autodétermination
sortir du giron de pékin
si oui mais la police a interdit la
tenue d'une grande manifestation ce
samedi pour les 5 ans du mouvement des
parapluies qui demandait justement
l'instauration du suffrage universel à
hong kong
et c'est une première depuis le
soulèvement du mois de juin
trois députés ont aussi été arrêtés pour
complot et obstruction à la police
respecte
l'union européenne se dit très inquiète
appelle les autorités à respecter le
droit de se rassembler la chine a
multiplié les menaces d'intervention ces
derniers temps comme ici quand elle a
remplacé hier sa garnison basé à hong
kong
et malgré l'interdiction de nouveaux
affrontements avec les forces de l'ordre
sont à craindre dans les prochaines
heures
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal